So the next game with the clear
intention of playing faster. The last
three times I
exceeded the time in the fat position because I
was so slow. Well, I ca
n't think of anything else, so now I have to
play a little faster. Knight D2
is of course
strange and black now immediately gets an
advantage in the center
so I'm trying not to
look for a direct rebuttal but to play a little
faster. W black is
now good anyway, pretty much no matter what you
play as long as you don't
put anything away, you just have a
center advantage, that's the idea  Now,
of course, E5 prevents it, it's not
strange or he does
n't react to it at all, so now I just have
the center for
nothing, so knight E4 picks up the bishop's par,
so maybe he'll make
E4 or
C4 gain a bit of
space here  or drive the knight away with A4.
Opponent is somewhere from
Qatar m with around
2000 yes he really played E4 well
first of all scare the knight
away so
the good thing about that place where you have the center
is very often that the knights do
n't have any clever squares
like queen  He will take B6 now,
okay, but I ca
n't prevent that very well anyway. I can play Queen A5,
why not? Yes,
Queen
A5
like that and now C3 is also hanging, yes I'll take it
away if he takes it to d5 now,
I also have the Zuch  E4 yes yes,
I'm not clearly in
the time to think
disadvantage yes well, we'll have to see what
he's doing now, he can
also make strange moves in between Tower
C1 or something like that, so now it's an
interesting question whether you can
still use it somehow  or whether you
directly make the actually desirable move
E3
E3 yes well I'll take it away first that's
strahbauer me so that the queen
takes I have bishop
E6 he can't take E4 because of bishop
B3 and then all the pieces are good if
he just if he takes that  I don't take
Queen E5 and just have one more with
the pair of bishops and totally in the
center so let's just
play so messing up the position
for time is
really a bit
stupid, yes, well then I'll go
to E5 and now you have  just one
more two bishops and the center yes the
apawn is still weak, although it is a
passed pawn
but it is still weak
and under certain circumstances you can
even play the whole D4 D3 straight away
so it is still hanging
between the
decks
so a direct possibility would now be
E4 E3  I mean
E3 but well, I don't have to
rush anything, no, we the position is
really that
good, I'll make a general
reinforcement move because it ca
n't
do anything, and now maybe just
double on the A-file against the pawn,
yes, something like that can happen  he plays okay,
what's wrong now with the move E3 Queen
E3 then loses the C4 and FE looks
terrible okay
E3 so well then he
may have got one again here
but E3 is of course still hanging
so Bishop D5 Queen D5 can  I
hit A2 so tower D5 yes now
take E3 E3 with the tower maybe there's
a catch I don't see any at the
moment so you can see otherwise the move
like H5 has now proven itself because
otherwise it would be tower D8 because it's
unpleasant often so you  Sometimes
an edge pawn move like H4 or H5 in
this case is often useful because the
piece gains a bit of space when reinforced
and there is still an
air gap in
power. Of course I did
n't see the variant like that but now it fits
in exactly so
Dausch actually  Yes, not necessarily, no,
I mean, it's good,
but it's good, but before we think about whether we
want to swap ladies, think about whether
we can actually go away somewhere,
probably because you ca
n't really do that well, no, you ca
n't do it well either, then we'll swap
just the question of where to go but still
trying to get the AR on
check
so so now he still
can't
pull the aborn
so and now we have to see that
our stuff here gets rolling with F5 and so on
so let's ask it again
Then he really never goes
forward, so now first of all
you can improve the runner, you can improve
the runner E7, yes, you can still
play, I don't know exactly where he
wants to go, well, I'll start running here now,
so let's look at G3 like he does now
covers without losing the knight
or something like that, well, the game is
easiest now with the two
passed pawns, it's also ideal to stand here with
the rook, yes, okay then I'll take the route
like that, yes
Rook G5 Be careful not to
rush, let's put something away
first
the so and now run to G5
so that wins the F5
still yes W times we times faster yes
opponent loses on time and I
still have 35
seconds principle he has
somehow played the opening so super
undemanding and
then here after with the center  Given
that, I could have tried knight 2 after F3 or something like that,
okay, I'll do
knight E4 or knight H5 to E5. That's the only way I can get to E5. It
was already a super
comfortable position, with the two bishops
and the center you actually have to be in a good
position  yes, no special
counterplay here